how old are you when you lost your  virginity 15.  she's like young cute  okay let's go around I was a late  bloomer too I think uh 19. I forgot I  think 16 17. I was 16. I was like 20. I  was like 20. but he's only been with one  girl let's go sweetheart oh my God isn't  that the sweetest [ __ ] so disgusting was  your sweat technically it was eighth  grade because we didn't really do  anything it was in there and then we got  scared oh okay I was so that's true  scared I was like damn I think I'm  pregnant you know I went to Vegas you  know what those like fortune teller  um oh the one you pay 50 cents yeah you  mean the robot I literally was like in  my pregnant I literally asked imagine if  it responds all loud no you are not  pregnant shut up shut up you gave me  like a vague answer ask again whether or  not you are pregnant  Maybe  only as pregnant as you feel